los demócratas están muy cerca de lograr
mantener el control del senado 4 días
después de la fecha oficial de la
elección Se confirmó la victoria de Mark
Kelly en el estado de Arizona resultó
reelecto y superó a republicano Black
Masters Aliado del ex presidente Donald
Trump así las cosas ambos partidos
tienen ahora 49 escaños y ahora el
control de la cámara alta se juega en
dos estados claves Nevada y Georgia
Nevada todavía no pudo oficializar los
resultados allí es republicano Adam
laxol tiene una muy estrecha ventaja
sobre su adversario Katherine cortes más
tú en este estado sábado es el último
día para recibir votos por correo lo que
explica el retraso
hacemos todo lo que está en nuestras
manos para que las papeletas avancen lo
más rápido posible pero con los plazos
que tenemos no puedo terminar el conteo
hasta que lleguen todos los correos es
un número muy pequeño pero aún así no
puedo terminar antes del sábado
en caso de reelección para la candidata
demócrata el partido de Jovi del monte
tendría su control del senado con 50
escaños ya que el voto de desempate
recae sobre la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris pero en caso de Victoria
republicana Nevada el futuro del senador
se jugará nuevamente en el estado de
Georgia donde una segunda vuelta se
celebrará el 6 de diciembre entre el
demócrata Rafael warnock y ya no se
publican Walker se espera una feroz
batalla final con una avalanza de fondos
de campaña lejos de la marea roja
augurada por las encuestas los
republicanos están ahora a sólo siete
escaños de quedarse con una muy estrecha
mayoría en la cámara de representa